this is what heavy industry does to our
planet inside the Arctic Circle nature
pitted against soviet-era factories a
chemical death for all forms of life on
May the 29th
Vasiliy rabinin was told there'd been an
accident theater he just started work
for the local branch of Russia's
environmental watchdog cross pyramids or
the water was already heavy with diesel
blending with the red sludge that he
says is a feature of the city's polluted
waterways the leak was coming from this
fuel tank on the left one of four
rusting belonging to a subsidiary of
nickel and palladium giant nor nickel
holders within a matter of hours 21,000
tons of diesel fuel had flooded into two
nearby rivers the worst-ever industrial
spill and the polar Arctic
the Kremlin only found out about it from
reports on social media subdued looking
officials reporting including on the
left Vladimir Putin President as the
deputy head of the local environmental
regulator the opinion had asked to take
a helicopter to check the impact further
north but he told Sky News producer anis
to Cle Oliver that he was advised not to
get involved
hi Dima yes I mean obviously the way
that nobody also probably a pioneer Tom
zona de removing you go area estimate
over geothermally then you might say me
do I miss Amelia what she did not and so
he quit detailing the obstacles he says
were put in his way in a long statement
on YouTube the rusticity seen Jo rocky
Cavanaugh see on is an environmental
blogger he managed to slip past police
and roadblocks and take about the length
of Lake Pierce inna 1200 kilometers to
the river right on the other side
is modern school cos dis he says that
even there he found more than twice the
normal concentration of diesel products
in the water via nada and he says it's
crucial that independent researchers are
allowed free access to the entire region
to investigate further build Marines
here papazilla visceral surface I'll
never say guerilla Tom stow the Grazyna
you Davos would arise though was a
rotational such a skill metro
Nizam chilavert momento Grazyna Yuja
pressure always rep asana
huija para VAR slow very echo piscina
e-report hadiyyah-lah cars Kimura
Norilsk used to be a closed city to
protect industrial secrets foreigners
still need an invitation to come and no
nickel did not give us one but as
Russian citizens our Moscow team were
able to get into film non nickel is the
main employer the company headquarters
in all its Stalinist glory right in the
center further out the city morphs into
industrial decrepitude a jumble of pipes
and frostbitten brickwork
till now fines for environmental damage
have been small the government is
promising that will change but activists
say in nouriel's environmental
violations are everywhere and that
authorities are quick to block roads to
prevent them from investigating
Greenpeace Russia say police flew in by
helicopter to confiscate the fuel they
were using to get around by boat and
that they were stopped from flying their
Sun Orioles Airport we found out that we
need allowance from the Department of
Security of the company nor Nikhil
actually and we asked to show some logo
or some statement that proved that this
is legal that what is the basis for this
but we still don't understand this last
week they found another dump this time
of water used in industrial processes
pumped from a tailing pond directly into
the tundra nor Nikhil has acknowledged
that this was a flagrant violation and
Russia's Investigative Committee has
opened inquiries into both this leak and
the diesel spill the head of the
environmental regulator here on the
right
refused to comment to Sky News about Rio
Benin's claims that her agency was
working hand-in-hand with more nickel as
for nor Nikhil it says the critical
stage of the cleanup is over and it is
finally considering a foreign press trip
but Russia guards its Arctic secrets
closely and what other accidents are
waiting to happen here at a cost to
nature that even the richest men in
Russia can't cover Diana Magnay Sky News
Moscow